welcome to epigenetics 2 in this lecture
we will talk about DNA methylation but
before we start let's review what is
epigenetics epigenetics is the branch of
biology which studies the casual
interactions between genes and their
products which bring the phenotype into
being what happens through several
different mechanisms one of them is DNA
methylation but also histone
modification and regulation of
transcription with non-coding RNAs DNA
methylation is one of the epigenetic
modifications that regulate gene
expression today the standard tool for
studying DNA methylation is called visa
fight sequencing visa fight sequencing
allows researchers to study per
nucleotide methylation status of whole
genomes the technique does not require
any prior knowledge about the genome
that is studied or the sites of modified
DNA and how these affect transcription
this makes beatified sequencing a truly
unsupervised approach to studying gene
expression regulation DNA methylation is
an addition of methyl group to the
cytosine on the DNA molecule previously
it was believed that DNA methylation
blocks transcription of closeby genes
today our understanding of this
epigenetic regulation of genes is
rapidly changing DNA methylation
probably has many more functions both in
health and disease than was previously
associated with it before today DNA
methylation and different proteins
involved in this epigenetic regulation
are an active area of study visa fight
sequencing is a standard technique for
analyzing DNA methylation B sulphide
sequencing includes beatified treatment
of the biological samples and library
preparation for NGS sequencing library
preparation includes adapter ligation
step and PCR amplify
the library is then sequenced on the NGS
machine and bioinformatics analysis is
performed to find differentially
methylated regions in conditions under
study visa fight treatment of the DNA
molecule changes an unmethylated
cytosines into uracil while methylated
cytosines remain intact after PCR
amplification uracil is further modified
into signing two different approaches to
adapter ligation step of library
preparation exists the T bar info
platform can be used to analyze both
types of data
however we will focus here on the
non-directional library preparation
technique as it is a prevailing one due
to its lower costs floor directional
library adapters are designed so that
only original positive and original
negative strands of DNA are sequenced in
this type of library preparation the
final NGS reads will have unmethylated
cytosines converted to thymines while
the methylated cytosines will remain
intact for example in this short genomic
region also designs were converted to
thymines after b sulphide treatment and
PCR amplification in the non directional
approach the adapters are not specific
thus after PCR amplification four kinds
of DNA fragments are sequenced original
positive we're all unmethylated
cytosines are converted to thymines
and original negative where again all
unmethylated cytosines are converted to
thymines
in addition the library will include
complementary DNA to the converted
positive strand as well as complimentary
DNA to the converted negative strand
when aligning non-directional library to
reference genome the algorithm will
allow mismatch
of ctt and positive strand so that only
original positive fragments will be
analyzed and four negative strand d2a
mismatches will be allowed allowing
mismatches in alignment will impact the
downstream calculations of proposition
methylation state status and thus is an
important step in visa fight data
analysis basic be certified workflow of
data analysis includes the following
steps
uploading raj anomic reads cleaning
these reads from adapters and pcr
duplicates aligning the reads to the
reference genome allowing mismatches
according to the method used for library
preparation per position methylation
calling and finally identifying
methylated Islands and annotating these
as known genes promoters CPG Islands or
other regulatory genomic sequences D bio
info pack one has beefs with five
sequencing section dedicated to analysis
of DNA methylation data the algorithms
in visa fide section are arranged
according to the basic analysis steps
pre-processing alignment proposition
methylation calling segmentation of
genome to identify methylated Islands
and Ireland annotation to options of
data analysis are possible analysis of
each sample separately and alternatively
analysis of pair of samples that should
be compared according to the logic of
the experiment when analyzing each
sample separately one does not need to
determine groups of samples or samples
can be dragged into one group and
contrasts for this type of analysis will
be 1:1 as a result of the pipeline one
can expect separate tables for each
uploaded sample with identified
methylated genomic regions for positive
and negative strands separately in
contrast when differential methylation
of two samples is required the samples
need to be uploaded into separate groups
and contrasts must be set to minus 1 1 1
minus 1
the contrast ensure that both hyper
methylated regions and hypo methylated
regions are found the basic pipeline for
analysis of be sulphide sequencing data
aunty biome for platform looks like this
first the cleaning and pre-processing of
reads is performed then the alignment of
reads alignment algorithm segmental
implements a matching strategy based
unenhanced suffix arrays the parameters
for identifying library preparation
method and possible mismatches between
reads and reference genome are required
proposition methylation calling per
nuchal assigns scores estimated by
Poisson likelihood function to also
designs positions parameters are needed
for printing result files the nest
algorithm identified regions enriched by
high score methylated positions finally
annotation models allowed to cross
winner spine segments with known
annotated regions of the genome based on
the GTF file annotated regions as found
in GTF file can be extended so that
Vanessa found regions close to the known
regulatory element can be identified
with this element additionally more
stringent Binh s region filtering is
possible alignment of reads in both
options of analysis no contrasts and
contrasts will be similar and will be
performed on each sample separately in
non-directional library preparation
option
such as methyl see two types of
mismatches will be allowed when aligning
meats to the reference genome CDT
mismatch and aid to gene mismatch
when reads will be aligned the algorithm
determines which strand the read belongs
to positive no special manipulation of
read was needed for the album for the
alignment or negative read needed to be
reversed and complement needed to be
aligned thus after alignment stage of
the pipeline to result files are
expected per sample positive and
negative strand alignments for position
methylation calling will be performed
for each Sam filed separately in case of
no contrasts or using contrasts on
negative and positive samples separately
when no contrasts are needed for
positive strand all sigh designs
positions will be analyzed against tiny
and statistics will be calculated the
scores are based on the rate of
methylation estimated by Poisson
likelihood function for a negative
strand all adenine nucleotides will be
analyzed against quinine and statistics
will be calculated if contrasts are
chosen the subtraction of scores
calculated for each sample will be
performed the resulting score will be
given due to the impossibility of
segmentation of genome based on negative
scores to contrasts were selected this
ensures that both methylation status
when sample one is more methylated and
when sample one is less methylated than
sample two will be identified the
proposition methylation results can then
be analyzed for methylation Islands when
speaking about each sample separately or
differentially methylated regions
taking contrasts into account these
found regions of the genome can be
annotated according to the known genomic
regions as indicated in the GTF file
expected output offers annotation model
will be tables of crosses of the found
methylated regions with chosen
regulatory elements for each contrast
and each strand
please find separate tables attached the
table is divided into two parts by
delimiter the first part contains the
known annotated region and the second
part the found methylated region with
start and positions and segment score
and average result files the be suicide
seek pipeline can be found in the
download folder this folder contains two
types of results bin s segmentation
result files for each strand separately
and depending on the contrast option
separate for each sample or for each
contrast and additional type of result
files are the zip compressed files
containing annotation results when
extracting these files several tables
will be available for each contrast the
most full table in each folder
containing most information will be of
kind promoter intercept table each
strand in each contrast will have a
separate table as a final step of
analysis all results should be record
replicable if analysis was performed on
each sample separately we recommend to
retain methylation Islands only if it
was found in at least two samples in the
group if the analysis was performed on
contrast the differentially methylated
regions should be found in at least two
pairs of contrasting samples